seit dem tod des afroamerikaners george
wright wird in den usa wieder heftig
über rassismus und polizeigewalt
diskutiert und gestritten
diese ganze diskussion die bayern nie so
richtig weg aber neu ist dass sie jetzt
auch zu uns nach europa und nach
deutschland überschwappt denn auch wir
haben hier ein rassismus problem vor
allem auch rassismus gegen schwarze das
ist eigentlich nicht mehr zu bestreiten
die große frage die sich daraus ergibt
ist natürlich was kommt nach den
protesten was kann daraus folgern was
können wir dagegen tun und wir wollen
uns daher zuerst zunächst heute mal
ansehen wie die lage in den usa jetzt
gerade ist dafür spreche ich mit unserem
usa korrespondenten im at wissen gleich
und danach möchten wir über forderungen
sprechen aus der schwarzen community da
spreche ich mit dem aktivisten daniel
jammer in berlin fragen und kommentare
zu den ganzen komplex bitte gerne unten
rein stellen ich gucke was ich mitnehmen
kann aber denkt daran bitte sachlich
bleiben rassistischen postings werden
von uns so schnell wie möglich gelöscht
und die verfasser sie hatten dann
geblockt so aber gucken wir erstmal in
die usa wo das ganze jahr seinen
ursprung hat und dass die berechtigt
sind
das zeigt sich schon wenn man allein mal
auf die nackten zahlen guckt und dann
mal so vergleicht wie werden weiß und
wir werden schwarze behandelt und wie
leben sie
und das ganze hat andreas garbe für uns
gemacht
schwarze machen 13 4 prozent der us
bevölkerung aus das ist etwa jeder
siebte von den rund 1.000 menschen die
2009 10 von us polizisten erschossen
werden war jedoch jeder vierte schwarz
in kalifornien wurden schwarze
verkehrsteilnehmer 2018 fast doppelt so
oft aus reinem verdacht angehalten wie
weiße sie wurden dann fast dreimal so
oft durchsucht obwohl man beweismittel
häufiger bei weißen fand im jahr 2018
zählte das fbi über 16.000 vorsätzliche
tötungsdelikte im land fast 40 prozent
davon wurden von schwarzen begangen also
deutlich mehr als ihr bevölkerungsanteil
das liegt aber nicht an der hautfarbe
sondern an dem sozialen gefälle sagen
wissenschaftler
sie sehen einen direkten zusammenhang
zwischen armut und der
wahrscheinlichkeit gewalttaten mit
waffen zu verüben
schwarze verdienen deutlich schlechter
pro haushalt ein drittel weniger als der
us durchschnitt bei vergleichbaren job
und gleicher qualifikation bekommen
schwarze männer 25 prozent seltener eine
gehaltserhöhung als weiße jeder fünfte
schwarze in den usa lebt unterhalb der
armutsgrenze
bei weißen ist es etwa jeder zwölfte 6
prozent der schwarzen us bevölkerung
waren im januar arbeitslos bei weißen
waren es 3,1 prozent auch in den
gefängnissen sind schwarze massiv
überrepräsentiert rund ein drittel aller
häftlinge sind schwarz
und die haftstrafen für schwarze sind
neun prozent länger als die von weißen
bei gleicher straftat und vergleichbarer
vorgeschichte der heftige zahlen und
über diesen anti schwarzen rassismus in
den vereinigten staaten und die proteste
der schwarzen bürgerrechtler spreche ich
jetzt in unserem usa korrespondenten
elmar theveßen in washington und nicht
wundern dass er seinen mund nasenschutz
um hat das ist nämlich tatsächlich bei
uns im studio washington pflicht wenn
man zusammen in einem büro ist das sind
sie habe ich gerade nicht und sie haben
das blut abgenommen
vielen dank erstmal nach washington
grünen haben nach deutschland hallo
okay wir haben eine leichte verzögerung
das müssen wir berücksichtigen gucken
wir noch erstmal auf die aktuellen
entwicklungen können sie mir ein kurzes
update geben wie viele proteste gibt es
derzeit noch in den staaten und wie sie
in die aus
es gibt gar keine genauen zahlen wir
wissen wo das jeden tag wieder neue
proteste stattfinden das ist dem ganzen
land in vielen großen und kleinen
städten meistens beginnt es irgendwann
am späteren nachmittag wenn die leute
von ihrer arbeit eigentlich dann nicht
nach hause gehen sondern zum protest zur
demonstration gehen in der
überwältigenden mehrheit sind es
friedliche proteste gedenkfeiern es wird
auch richtig gefeiert ein bisschen party
stimmung herrscht da manchmal auf den
straßen hier auch in washington am
weißen aus aber es gibt eben auch an der
einen oder anderen stelle gewalt zum
beispiel den zettel in der vergangenen
nacht sehr heftige auseinandersetzungen
mit der polizei
und was neues in den letzten tagen
verstärkt ist dass die symbole des
rassismus
die statuen von südstaaten generellen
oder zum beispiel von jefferson davis
die präsidentin der südstaaten damals im
bürgerkrieg umgestürzt werden so jetzt
gerade wieder in richmond virginia
geschehen
das ist also eine heftige diskussion im
gange insgesamt muss man aber sagen ist
die überwältigende mehrheit der proteste
friedlich
das schwarze gegen diese diskriminierung
und ungleichbehandlung auf die straße
gehen das ist ja nichts neues das kennen
wir jetzt seit den 60ern spätestens und
ist immer wieder hoch gekommen auch in
den letzten zehn jahren ja immer wieder
warum ist diese ungleichbehandlung
eigentlich immer noch so eklatant in den
vereinigten staaten
ich glaube der wesentliche faktor wurde
auch vor in dem beitrag schon
angesprochen ist eine soziale
ungerechtigkeit wirtschaftliche
ungerechtigkeit in den usa die gerade in
den letzten jahrzehnten noch einmal
massiv sich vergrößert hat ich will man
auch damit zahlen nennen 1980
beispielsweise von 1980 bis heute hat
sich das bruttoinlandsprodukt der
vereinigten staaten um plus 79 prozent
entwickelt und die untere hälfte der
bevölkerung hat in der zeit eine
einkommensentwicklung bei der
arbeitenden bevölkerung von 40 prozent
gehabt während bei den 0,01 der
reichsten in der arbeitenden bevölkerung
in den usa die entwicklung plus 420
prozent war in den letzten 40 jahren
seit 1980 und das zeigt sehr deutlich
diese tiefe kluft am härtesten sind
davon die schwarzen betroffen
sie haben schlechtere chancen auf eine
gute ausbildung hängt auch ein bisschen
damit zusammen dass schon im
bildungssystem die schulen abhängig sind
von der grundsteuer die eingenommen wird
das heißt wenn sie in einem in einer
armen gegend leben dann hat eine schule
weniger geld zur verfügung um lehrmittel
zu kaufen um vielleicht auch mal eine
klassenfahrt zu ermöglichen das klingt
sehr banal aber da fängt es an
benachteiligung im bildungssystem das
geht dann weiter zwar sind aus denen ich
sag mal geringverdienenden
bevölkerungsgruppen mehr menschen in den
vergangenen jahren die tatsächlich auch
einen höheren abschluss anstreben
die also zu college gehen oder zur
universität aber die entsprechenden
zahlen der abschlüsse stimmen nicht
damit überein das heißt viele müssen auf
dem weg einen hochschulabschluss zu
machen aufgeben weil sie sich das nicht
mehr leisten können bildung ist
unglaublich teuer hier also insgesamt
hängt sehr viel mit der wirtschaftlichen
situation im land zu sein
da habe ich gleich eine frage hier aus
der community die fragt nämlich hier auf
youtube zum beispiel der user trust it
comes out möchte wissen das sagt doch
auch die zahlen die wir gerade gesehen
haben dass schwarze krimineller sind als
weiße warum ist da
nein das hat zunächst mal damit nichts
zu tun
es gibt höhere kriminalitätsrate das hat
aber mit drogen zu tun mit
hoffnungslosigkeit perspektivlosigkeit
ich sag mal man kann nicht jeden der in
diese situation hinein gerät dann
entschuldigen dass er dann eine straftat
begeht weil er halt schlechtere
rahmenbedingungen hat aber es erklärt
dass sehr viele schwarze auch deshalb in
der kriminalitätsstatistik auftauchen
weil man härter gegen sie vorgeht als
gegen weiß auch da ein beispiel wer mit
drogen erwischt wird und weiß ist hat
eine viel größere chance dass er ich sag
mal ungeschoren davon kommt dass er
keine zeit im gefängnis verbringen muss
als ein schwarzer das hat mit den
ungerechtigkeiten im strafjustiz system
in den usa zu tun und das weist auf
einen systemischen rassismus in denen es
gibt den man den zahlen belegen kann
aber es ändert nichts daran dass hier
der entscheidende punkt ist wenn sich
wirtschaftliche chancen verbessern gehen
mit sicherheit auch die
kriminalitätsraten nach unten aber in
erster linie entsteht dann eher 1 1
ich sag mal eine tendenz ein trend zu
mehr gleichheit und gerechtigkeit in den
usa und in den letzten zehn jahren hat
es sich genau in die gegenrichtung
entwickelt es gab ja in den 60ern diese
sehr prominenten figuren martin luther
king marke mexx die quasi dieses ganze
diese ganze bewegung kanalisiert haben
und dann auch ansprechpartner waren für
die politik auf deren worte wurde gehört
mir ist bis jetzt noch niemand
aufgefallen der zurzeit irgendwie so
heraus sticht braucht diese bewegungen
vielleicht so eine figur um
erfolgreicher zu sein
ich glaube nach meiner beobachtung nicht
momentan ist man sogar stolz darauf und
findet es ganz großartig dass ganz viele
menschen sich engagieren und auch ich
sag mal führende rolle übernehmen das
sind aber eben viele nicht die eine
große person das fängt an bei vielen
jungen leuten die in ihren zwanziger
jahren beispielsweise sind die auf den
straßen unterwegs sind die die proteste
organisieren die die logistik dahinter
organisieren die aufrufen damit mehr auf
die straße kommen es sind ältere die
sich über die letzten jahrzehnte auch
engagiert haben die vielleicht sogar
damals in den protestbewegungen der 60er
jahre schon dabei gewesen sind und es
sind auch viele amtsträger
beispielsweise allen voran die schwarzen
bürgermeisterinnen die wir hier in
vielen orten in den usa haben
beispielsweise die talents bottoms aus
atlanta oder hier maria browser in
washington laurie lightfoot in chicago
das sind die gesichter der bewegung und
dazu gesellen sich und das ist das
großartige immer mehr auch an
ich sag mal namhaften persönlichkeiten
unabhängig von ihrer hautfarbe auch
unterschiedlicher politischer richtungen
ehemalige generäle ehemalige minister
also ist eine bewegung geworden die in
die breite gegangen ist und die braucht
nicht notwendigerweise eine große
führungspersönlichkeit eine der
forderungen die man gerade jetzt ganz
häufig hört man nennt sich die fanta
police also entzieht der polizei quasi
das geld das klingt jetzt für unsere
ohren ein bisschen merkwürdig weniger
geld für sicherheitsbehörden was steckt
dahinter
ja geld weg klingt sehr radikal zunächst
mal aber in der tat ist damit nicht die
komplette abschaffung der polizei gemein
gehen den usa haben wir halt eine andere
situation als in deutschland in
deutschland wenn ein anruf kommt weil
jemand hilfe rat was auch immer braucht
intervention des staates gewissermaßen
dann landen viele dieser anrufe auch
beim ordnungsamt dann kommen ordnungsamt
beamte oder es kommen sozialarbeiter und
nicht gleich von vorneherein die polizei
das ist hier anders wer in einer neuen
welt der landet bei der polizei dann
erscheinen polizisten mit waffen am
gürtel und vor dem hintergrund glauben
viele das muss sich ändern wir brauchen
mehr personal in sozialarbeit und auch
vergleichbare strukturen wie
ordnungsämter in deutschland und
gleichzeitig kann man auch dafür sorgen
dass die polizei ich sag mal im
auftreten anders mit den menschen umgeht
es gibt modellprojekt in camden new
jersey da hat man vor jahren schon
erkannt das führt nicht dazu dass die
situation sich verbessert im gegenteil
sie eskaliert weiter also hat man der
polizei teilweise gelder und aufgaben
weggenommen diese gelder mehr in
konfliktlösungsmechanismen und
sozialarbeit gesteckt die polizei hat
man regelrecht ja man kann fast sagen
auseinandergenommen die polizeibehörde
stück für stück man hat eine neue
polizeibehörde gegründet und dann darauf
geachtet dass man die besten beamten
bekamen die in einer art und weise des
umgangs mit der bevölkerung halt mehr
für den bürger da sind als gegen manche
bürger wie man ja manchmal den eindruck
hatte und das hat auch dafür gesorgt
dass die macht der polizeigewerkschaften
in camp in new jersey gebrochen worden
ist weil da liegt auch ein problem dass
polizisten hier in den usa oft genug
nicht zur rechenschaft gezogen werden
wenn sie die regeln brechen weil ihre
gewerkschaften dafür sorgen dass solche
fälle auch geheim bleiben das glaube ich
wird sich auch in den nächsten wochen
und monaten hier an vielen orten in den
usa ändern
hier gibt es eine kritische nachfrage zu
ihrer äußerung ist sei schlechter
geworden in den usa von michael
ohlenschläger auf youtube der meint was
ist mit barack obama erster schwarzer
präsident es gibt schwarze bürgermeister
was sagen sie dazu also im grunde ist
sie ja doch einen wandel
ja es gab natürlich große hoffnungen
dass barack obama derjenige sein werde
der die situation für alle verbessert
fakt ist natürlich wenn der wesentliche
faktor die wirtschaft des landes ist
muss man sagen obama trat an während der
wirtschaftskrise 2008 2009 und wir sehen
über die zeit obamas hinaus natürlich
auch jetzt in der tram zeit das war
danach nach der wirtschaftskrise immer
wieder neue jobs auch geschaffen worden
sind viele millionen übrigens in beiden
amtszeiten bei trump und bei barack
obama aber es sind oft jobs im
niedriglohnsektor es sind nicht neue
chancen entstanden für junge leute
schwarze hispanics jedenfalls nicht
genug weil der abstand zwischen arm und
reich größer geworden ist und da kommt
glaube ich noch ein faktor 1
wir haben in den letzten jahren ja auch
den niedergang ich sag mal der weißen
arbeiterklasse erlebt das heißt die
gleichen probleme dass die gehälter die
löhne nicht gestiegen sind während die
inflation zugenommen hat dass die
menschen ihre jobs auch da verloren
haben das hat zwischen weißen und
schwarzen den vielen gegenden in den usa
die gegensätze noch mal verschärft im
grunde genommen
bei weißen in der arbeiterklasse das
gefühl entstehen lassen dass barack
obama beispielsweise etwas für
minderheiten in amerika tut aber zu
wenig für sie selber das ist genau der
grund weshalb genau diese menschen
donald trump 2016 gewählt haben
und das hier ist eigentlich das
hauptproblem das heißt im wahlkampf
jetzt kommt es darauf an dass konzepte
von den kandidaten vorgestellt werden
wie es für alle in diesem bereich in der
arbeiterklasse besser werden kann
ich glaube dass eine voraussetzung dafür
dass das land weniger polarisiert und
einiger wird in zukunft das ist genau
das richtige stichwort auf das ich
gewartet hat war sie nämlich der
präsidentschaftswahlkampf der ja gerade
läuft das geht so ein bisschen und habe
ich manchmal das gefühl zwischen diesen
ganzen meldungen die da kommen kohona
und jetzt die proteste kann es sein dass
das was da jetzt passiert ist oder was
gerade noch passiert an protesten an
schwarzen bürgerrechtsbewegung und
tatsächlich auch einen einfluss hat auf
die präsidentschaftswahl
ja ich glaube ganz klar und eindeutig
wir sehen das an den zahlen
wir sehen dass donald trump in der
zustimmung verliert er liegt jetzt bei
38% beispielsweise wir sehen das auch
seine kern klientel die vorhin erwähnte
weiße arbeiterklasse also weiße ohne
einen hochschulabschluss oder auch
ältere menschen in den usa die die in
großer zahl vor drei jahren fast vier
jahren dafür gesorgt haben dass donald
trump gewählt worden ist
da sind seine zustimmungsraten so
deutlich gesunken dass das wenn sich
nicht noch viel verändert in den
nächsten monaten natürlich auswirkungen
an der wahl ohne haben wird und deswegen
werden wir hier in den nächsten monaten
auch einen kampf darum erleben
ob man wählen kann ob die
rahmenbedingungen für die wahl so sind
dass alle gleichen zugang haben zur wahl
da bemühen sich die republikaner an
verschiedenen in verschiedenen
bundesstaaten darum dass wählen zu
erschweren wenden sich gegen
beispielsweise die briefwahl wählen sie
wenden sich dafür dass die
rahmenbedingungen verschärft werden will
man beispiel nennen das wenn man seine
identität nachweis dann im wahllokal der
name den man auch seinem ausweis hat
hundert prozent übereinstimmen muss mit
dem was in der wählerliste steht also
kein buchstabe anders und es gibt leider
in vielen gegenden in den usa probleme
mit diesen wählerlisten wo die namen
nicht wirklich ordentlich aufgeführt
sind und auf dieser basis sind
beispielsweise in georgia hier in den
usa bei den letzten wahlen viele
menschen ist die die wahl verweigert
worden sie durften nicht wählen und das
wird eine große auseinandersetzung geben
in den nächsten monaten wie sehr die
menschen die jetzt ich sag mal motiviert
sind wählen zu gehen am ende auch wählen
dürfen
der präsident hat schon angekündigt dass
er in den verschiedensten bundesstaaten
mit allen mitteln beispielsweise
verhindern will dass es briefwahl gibt
und die rahmenbedingungen auch
verschärft werden soll weil das sagt er
sogar ganz offen wenn viele menschen zur
wahl gehen verlieren die republikaner
das hat er gesagt das ist ein zitat von
ihm also insofern werden wir uns auf
eine große auseinandersetzung auch um
die wahlen am dritten november
einstellen müssen das ganze wird also
spannend und spannend bleibt auch die
frage wie lange diese ungerechtigkeit
ungleichheit noch so
eklatante den usa ist der aktivisten
dankeschön für ihre ganzen informationen
eindrücke aber würde bei uns gibt es ja
auch noch einiges zu tun rassismus ist
ein tägliches thema gerade auch für
menschen mit schwarzer hautfarbe für
schwarze und wir haben drei prominente
gefragt wie sie das eigentlich erleben
und was sie sich wünschen
und er mich immer noch an gestartet
nämlich zurückgegangen kann ich
irgendwie helfen und er meinte sie
einfach ganz direkt ins gesicht
ich beobachte sie nur weil bei negern
muss ja mal auch muss man immer
aufpassen was die so gefährlich ist aus
der tasche ziehen dass man unterschätzt
wird dass man fähigkeiten abgesprochen
bekommt dass man stereotypisierung wird
dass menschen anfangen in die plötzlich
langsamer oder deutlicher mit einem zu
sprechen
manchmal gerne auch etwas lauter und
bringt er ja ok verstehe ich jetzt nicht
was das ganze soll der rassismus wird
offener direkter weil die leute sich
jetzt ganz offensichtlich trauen dinge
die sie zuvor viel leistung im kleinen
kreis geäußert haben um noch eine
öffentlichkeit zu sagen in jeglichen
bereichen ist man damit konfrontiert und
es ist ein täglicher begleiter und die
banalisierung dessen das ist in
deutschland keine pro kein problem ist
führt dazu dass man sich auch hier
natürlich nicht ernst genommen fühlt im
adressieren von anti schwarzen rassismus
der hier existiert werden auch gerne der
begriff kommissions kinder ja so ganz
niedlich sind und das ist sehr billig in
der tat sehr schwierig da haben auch
große teile der politik und der medien
im teil dazu beigetragen dass diese
menschen sich jetzt wohl fühlen und das
gefühl haben sie türen in rassismus ganz
offen zur schau stellen weil angeblich
in ihrem weltbild eine schweigende
mehrheit hinter ihnen steht in dem
augenblick wo man ihm zuhören sollte
wird das gespräch verdreht das sind dann
zum beispiel so momente wo dann sätze
fallen wie aber es gibt ja auch
rassismus gegen weiße die
auseinandersetzung mit diesem thema
politischen zivilgesellschaftlich noch
viel stärker stattfinden wir haben in
deutschland keine aufarbeitung in der
form die notwendig ist um zu verstehen
wie rassisten
eigentlich in deutschland halt auch
salonfähig geworden ist gegenüber
schwarzen menschen was menschen die
selbst vielleicht nicht von rassismus
betroffen sind sich trotzdem aktiv gegen
rassismus positionieren und zwar nicht
nur auf social media gerne auch auf
social media aber es mussten schritt
weiter gehen wir müssen auch im alltag
bereits sein unsere stimme zu erheben
wir müssen eine ehrliche art hinweise
finden mit der debatte um zu gehen und
zwar eine ehrliche debatte in der es um
die gefühle der betroffenen geht nicht
um die gefühle von denen und den
rassismus aus wird ich glaube es geht
aber gar nicht darum grundsätzlich nur
anschuldigungen zu machen sondern einmal
zu erklären woher kommen ihre sitze und
was können wir dagegen tun um als
gesellschaft geeintes zu sein ganz oft
erlebe ich diesen reflex von vom weißen
freundin dann alles in frage zu stellen
also bist du dir sicher dass das
rassistisch gemeint war bildest du das
vielleicht ein bist du vielleicht ein
bisschen empfindlich ich kann mir das
überhaupt nicht vorstellen
und da ich mir ja du kannst dir nicht
vorstellen weil du weißt ist und
deswegen als selig ist die als dein
freund bitte glaubt mir ja also selber
aktiv werden nicht nur schwarze bildchen
posten social media sondern tatsächlich
sich bilden den mund aufmachen das sind
dabei keine wirklich neuen forderungen
die kommen dafür von daniel jammer
der ist mir jetzt in berlin zugeschaltet
ich muss mal ganz kurz ihre ganzen
positionen ablesen weil es sind viele
also sie arbeiten als bereichsleiter des
berliner sphinx it is for europe zum
thema vielfalt diversity in dieser chip
also mit führungspersönlichkeiten aber
ehrenamtlich sind sie auch tätig im
vorstand von itron teach one dessen
organisation zum im powerwind von
schwarzen afrikanischen afro
diastolischen menschen in deutschland
und im vorstand der neuen deutschen
organisationen das ist ein bundesweites
netzwerk von rund 120 vereinen
organisationen die vor allem aus
menschen mit migrationshintergrund
bestehen
und sie haben einen artikel geschrieben
gerade vor fünf tagen bei zeit online wo
sie fünf forderungen aufstellen können
sie die uns mal kurz versuchen
zusammenzufassen
schön bunt haben danke für die einladung
wir sehen gerade eine situation wo in
den usa ein rassistischer polizei mord
stattgefunden hat und alle menschen in
der welt und in deutschland auf die
straße gehen und das entscheidende ist
jetzt die frage wie man diesen
von der straße in die verwaltung und die
politik bekommt und ich will gar nicht
bei 5 forderung bleiben soll ich will
bei einer einzigen bleiben die sehr
relevant ist bundeskanzlerin angela
merkel hat zum ersten mal ein
sogenanntes anti rassismus kabinett
ausgerufen sozusagen eines der höchsten
beschlussgremium das überhaupt möglich
ist
es soll darum gehen dass die zuständigen
ministerinnen und minister sich an den
tisch setzen und überlegen wie wir mit
rassismus und rechtsradikalismus
antisemitismus in deutschland umgehen
und eine unserer zentralen forderungen
ist es das anti schwarzer rassismus in
deutschland und vor allem strukturelle
rassismus auf die tagesordnung kommt die
bundesregierung hat in den letzten
jahren in unterschiedlichsten berichten
an die vereinten nationen anerkannt dass
es in deutschland unter anderem vier
gruppen gibt die in besonderer weise von
rassistischer diskriminierung betroffen
sind
dazu gehören neben der jüdischen
community der muslimischen community
oder menschen die als muslime markiert
sind und natürlich schwarzen menschen
auch sinti und roma leider machen wir
immer wieder die erfahrung dass die
bedürfnisse die erfahrungen schwarzer
menschen in der verwaltung in der
politik hinten runter fallen können sie
mir das mal einer erklären ist genau was
also wo unterscheiden sich von schwarzen
menschen von ich sage mal menschen mit
jüdischer religionszugehörigkeit von
muslimen von menschen mit anderen
migrationshintergrund sie unterscheiden
sich nicht sozusagen den bedürfnissen
von den anderen communitys sondern wir
und auch viele andere communitys machen
immer wieder die erfahrung dass die
spezifischen rassismen die unsere
community sein leben hinter runterfallen
ein beispiel ist die neue polizeiliche
kriminalitätsstatistik taucht jetzt
unter anderem das wort
deutschenfeindlichkeit auf und
statistiken dazu und wir fragen uns
sozusagen aus einer fach expertise was
soll denn das sein wenn es um
feindlichkeit gegenüber deutschen geht
es gibt auch sehr viele schwarze
deutsche die sind aber offensichtlich
damit nicht gemeint wenn es darum geht
angeblichen rassismus gegenüber weißen
menschen fragen wir uns was das
inhaltlich bedeuten soll
es gibt aber bis jetzt keine statistiken
zu anti schwarzen rassismus und wie
häufig er beispielsweise bei verbrechen
auftaucht dass so ein kleines beispiel
wo wir immer wieder die erfahrung machen
dass die politik und die verwaltung die
erfahrungen unserer community ist nicht
auf dem tisch haben
also es wird quasi unsichtbar gemacht
das ist so ein bisschen der vorwurf oder
es wird gar nicht hingeschaut dass es
sowas spezifisches gibt es jetzt zum
ersten mal dass wir überhaupt in
deutschland auch in der presse über
schwarze menschen reden ja in
deutschland leben über eine million
menschen afrikanischer herkunft ist eine
sehr sehr große community und eine der
jüngsten communitys und es brauchte
jetzt diesen mord in den usa und dem
globalen aufschrei dass es überhaupt zur
debatte wird hier ja wir haben
bundeskanzlerin angela merkel vor ein
paar wochen gehört wie sie auf einer
pressekonferenz zum ersten mal über
schwarze menschen gesprochen hat aber
wir sind zur zeit in der un dekade für
menschen afrikanischer herkunft die
läuft bis 2024 und bis jetzt gibt es
keinen aktionsplan keinen maßnahmenpaket
um diese aktuell dekade mit leben zu
füllen und zu wecken und wir sehen dass
vor allem die zuständigen ministerien
einmal das familienministerium das
innenministerium in der verantwortung an
die schwarzen rassismus als
strukturelles phänomen in deutschland
sozusagen zu besprechen und dagegen
vorzugehen
sie haben gerade schon ein stich volk
gegeben das hat mit den forderung nichts
zu tun aber ich glaube es ist ganz
wichtig jetzt in der diskussion auch
hier unter den usern nämlich rassismus
gegen weiße sie haben gesagt sie wissen
nicht was das sein soll
hier wird aber genau das gefragt es gibt
doch auch rassismus gegen deutsche
es wird immer wieder das beispiel
genannt mann wird als kartoffel
beschimpft oder oder andere
schimpfwörter können sie das vielleicht
mehr differenzieren wir uns aus ihrer
sicht rassismus gegen weiße nicht geht
warum sie sich fragen was das sein soll
also ich kann verstehen dass weiße
menschen von seiner bezeichnung
betroffen sind vielleicht emotional
gekränkt sind aber rassismus ist ja ein
globales phänomen mit 400 jahren 500
jahren kolonialgeschichte was dazu
geführt hat dass weiß den menschen in
allen gesellschaftlichen bereichen vor
allem im westen privilegiert sind und
schwarzen menschen people of colour de
privilegiert sind nur ein ganz kleines
beispiel wenn wir uns das kabinett
anschauen wie soll ich das kabinett
sondern die führungsriege von
innenminister seehofer ja dann wurde
waren sieben personen acht personen auf
dem foto sichtbares war in den medien
gegen das hoch und runter und danach
wurde gesagt okay da sind nur frauen
fehlen auf diesem foto
da sind aber auch alles nur weiße
menschen wir leben in einer gesellschaft
in der eigentlich
fast alle führungspositionen von weißen
menschen sozusagen belegt sind
und dann gibt es gegebenenfalls auch
diskriminierung gegenüber weißen
menschen sei es beispielsweise gegenüber
weißen frauen werden oder weißen
menschen aus ostdeutschland das ist aber
kein rassismus und es ganz wichtig dass
sozusagen zu differenzieren zu sagen
okay rassismus ist ein globales system
was weißen menschen privilegiert eine
forderung von ihnen ist ja die förderung
von schwarzen menschen in deutschland
wie stellen sie sich das genau vor das
ist so ein bisschen vage gehalten heißt
dass stipendien heißt das besondere
programme oder wie soll das aussehen das
muss ich in alle gesellschaftlichen
bereiche ziehen ich will mal ein
beispiel machen das familienministerium
hat bis jetzt gerade das größte
förderprogramm sag ich mal zu vielfalt
und gegen diskriminierung in deutschland
so genanntes demokratie leben programm
und in diesem programm ist es seit
einigen jahren zum ersten mal der fall
dass unsere organisation von teach one
gefördert wird was aber nicht passiert
ist das beispielsweise bereich der
modellprojekte schwarz menschen
spezifisch benannt werden wie andere
komitees auch und das in power nennt
innerhalb der community also der
struktur aufbau einer starken schwarzen
zivilgesellschaft sozusagen nicht auf
der agenda steht das geht weiter in den
bereich des sogenannten demokratie
förder gesetzes er ist eine forderung
die es schon lange in der
zivilgesellschaft gibt in der
antirassistischen zivilgesellschaft dass
es ein gesetzliche grundlage braucht
indem man längerfristig antirassistische
initiativen unterstützen können muss und
das geht natürlich weiterhin alle
anderen gesellschaftlichen bereichen es
gibt unterschiedliche stipendien werke
und wir wissen dass es auch in den
stipendien werken der großen sozusagen
geldgeber innen schwarzen menschen
unterrepräsentiert sind das trotz
menschen sich teilweise gar nicht
bewerben und den weg durch die
institutionen schaffen und das beispiel
mit dem stipendien berg in anlehnung an
das awi zehner stipendien berg für
muslime muslimische talente haben wir
aufgegriffen um zu sagen okay wenn
deutschland wirklich ein interesse hat
das schwarzen menschen mit am tisch
sitzen mit über diese gesellschaft
entscheiden dann braucht es auf englisch
nennt man das so genannte talent
pipelines erst braucht sozusagen schnell
bahnlinien wo unsere talente unterstützt
werden um den gang durch die
institutionen zu schaffen aber kann das
nicht dazu führen dass es dann genau
diesen vorwurf gibt vor denen sich auch
manche in der frauenbewegung im
fürchten oder wären täglich dass nur
diese förderung in diese position nur
weil ihr eine andere hautfarbe habt und
das dann quasi die persönliche
qualifikation unter den tisch fällt und
dass man sich immer rechtfertigen muss
warum man doch da den richtigen platz
hat das ist vorhersehbar dass es solche
argumente geben wird und dass genau das
gleiche sehen weil ja wie sie selber
schon gesagt haben im bereich der
geschlechtergerechtigkeit
es wird akteure geben die sagen werden
um mein gott
damit machen wir doch eigentlich das
problem noch viel größer wir wissen aber
in der schwarzen community aus
jahrzehnten erfahrungen dass es leider
nicht anders möglich sein wird als zwei
sachen zu machen einmal das thema zum
mainstream das heißt eine rassismus
kritische perspektive auch verwaltung
auf organisationen muss in allen
bereichen vorangebracht werden
mit einer so genannten internationalen
perspektive dass man es sagt zum
beispiel
wir schauen uns nicht nur an wie frauen
und weiße frauen von diskriminierung
betroffen sind sondern eben auch
spezifisch schwarze frauen und darüber
hinaus müssen wir die
unterrepräsentierten communitys explizit
unterstützen und fördern dass sie selbst
mit ihren netzwerken den gang in diese
institution schaffen und dann wird es
ein paar kritikpunkte geben dass man
sagt okay du hast das nur aufgrund der
und der förderung erhalten aber das
halten wir aus und wer soll das genau
machen ist das eine sache also die von
der bundesregierung der
landesregierungen weil es ist ja schon
so sie haben dann ziemlich harte kritik
gegen die institutionen sagen da gibt es
strukturellen rassismus das lassen sich
natürlich institutionen nicht so richtig
gerne sagen und dann wird es
wahrscheinlich auch ihr widerstand darin
geben das sieht man ja auch jetzt bei
der polizei wo sich teile vehement
dagegen wehren zu sagen wir haben ja
keinen strukturellen rassismus wir sind
doch dazu da die grundrechte zu
verteidigen und unterschiedliche punkte
die sie da angesprochen haben einmal
wenn wir noch mal das beispiel der
talentförderung nehmen würde ich sagen
kann man sich einfach die homepage ist
anschauen von den großen förder werken
oder die letzten jahrgänge und fragen
sind denn diese talente repräsentativ
für die vielfalt in dieser gesellschaft
und das sind sie ganz klar nicht da gibt
es mehrere studien dazu dass auch diese
stipendien werke sozusagen unsere
bestehenden eliten reproduzieren dass
das mittel auf jeden fall das sehen wir
auch im bereich der
geschlechtergerechtigkeit ohne quoten
werden wir sozusagen die vielfalt in der
gesellschaft nicht repräsentiert sehen
sie hatten noch das beispiel der polizei
genannt die sich dagegen wehrt von
institutioneller diskriminierung zu
sprechen ich muss ehrlich sagen das ist
nicht verwunderlich aber sehr sehr
enttäuschend
ja und zwar nicht nur für die schwarze
community sondern auch für alle anderen
von rassismus betroffenen communitys in
deutschland wenn es leider ein punkt
gibt der uns alle in großen teilen
verbindet ist es die erfahrung von
rassistischen polizeikontrollen ob wir
jugendliche in unseren projekten fragen
in berlin stuttgart hamburg
deutschlandweit wenn wir fragen was sind
denn erfahrungen mit rassistischer
diskriminierung in deutschland kommt
polizeigewalt oder racial profiling auf
jeden fall kommt der bildungssektor und
beispielsweise auch noch der wohn
sektoren so und jetzt in berlin wurde ja
das sogenannte landes
antidiskriminierungsgesetz vor kurzem
verabschiedet vor wenigen tagen werden
die kommentiert sich darüber gefreut
dass es erstmalig eine gesetzliche
grundlage gibt hier zum beispiel berlin
auf landesebene man gegen
diskriminierung durch die verwaltung
vorgehen kann
so und jetzt würden wir uns wünschen von
der politik dass diese gesetze nicht von
der polizei angegangen werden und so zu
sagen man direkt in eine
verteidigungshaltung geht sondern
anerkennt dass die polizei nicht nur die
polizei von weißen deutschen ist sondern
auch die polizei des vielfältigen
deutschlands von schwarzen deutschen von
people of colour die hier leben und wenn
wir sagen dass es eine jahrzehntelange
wenn ich jahrhundertelange erfahrung in
unserem komitees ist dass wir nicht
einmal kontrolliert werden sondern immer
und immer und immer und immer und immer
wieder das ist so richtig monoton immer
und immer wieder und es geht auch nicht
nur darum dass ich als individuum
kontrolliert werde sondern dass man
mitbekommt mein onkel wird kontrolliert
meine tante wird kontrolliert es gibt
schon clips darüber online wo leute
kontrolliert werden dass es auf jeden
fall ein strukturelles problem ist und
die polizei sollte er sagen okay unser
anspruch ist es dass alle menschen die
in deutschland einen beitrag leisten zur
gesellschaft wertgeschätzt werden da
gehen wir mit aber wir als polizei die
einzige einheit ist die sozusagen mit
waffengewalt das staatliche
gewaltmonopol durchsetzt müssten doch an
der speerspitze sein eines diskurses um
eine diskriminierungsfreie oder
zumindest kriegen das gründungs
kritische verwaltung deshalb haben wir
da ganz andere
anforderungen als so eine
verteidigungshaltung so ich muss mal
kurz hier in wort an unsere
kommentatoren richten weil ich lese ich
die kommentare
da kann ich mir sagen die gefallen mir
nicht die gehen einfach überhaupt nicht
sich darüber zu wundern dass unser
deutscher gesprächspartner deutsch
spricht ist rassistisch und sowas wird
gelöscht und so was dürfen wir hier
nichts und das ist meine ganz klare
ansage hier aus der redaktion so wir
machen weiter im gespräch
sie haben auch vorgeschlagen dass das so
was wie black studies und anti schwarzen
rassismus als lehrfach an unis geben
soll
das klingt jetzt schon relativ speziell
was erhoffen sie sich denn von so einer
forschungsrichtung tust dann nicht auch
ich sage mal generell das fach rassismus
forschung was ist ja schon liebt und da
will ich widersprechen es gibt viel zu
wenig lehrstühle die rassismus kritisch
in deutschland forschen wir kennen das
auch beispielsweise aus den usa da gibt
es so genannte traditional black college
oder in großbritannien ganze
studiengänge zu black studies warum wir
das gefordert haben das übrigens keine
forderungen nur von mir und sarah gummis
mit der ich den artikel zusammen
verfasst haben sondern ist eine
jahrzehntelange forderung die unter
anderem von schwarzen feministinnen von
ade fr schon sehr sehr lange in den raum
gestellt wird warum wir sehen in allen
bereichen beispielsweise im bereich
bildung im bereich jugend im bereich
bibliotheken das noch sehr sehr viel
mehr grundlagenarbeit gemacht werden
muss ja wenn beispielsweise lehrerin
rassismus kritisch ausgebildet werden
sollen und wenn wir in einem zustand
sind wo wir sagen in deutschland leben
so viele schwarze menschen und es gibt
nicht einen einzigen lehrstuhl nicht
einen einzigen lehrstuhl der sich
dezidiert damit beschäftigt wie man denn
die lebenssituation von schwarzen
menschen in deutschland verbessern kann
und wir gleichzeitig wissen wir leben in
einem land wo die politik durch die
forschung informiert wird und ihre
politik auf fakten basiert dann müssen
wir uns nicht wundern dass anti
schwarzen rassismus kein thema ist in
der politik wir in der schwarzen
community machen wir uns seit zehn
jahren erzählt jahrzehnten forschung
außerhalb des universitären system
beispielsweise jetzt gerade bringen wir
den afro zensus auf die schiene der in
wenigen tagen startet das wird die
größte bis dato online befragung unter
der schwarzen afrikanischen afro der
session kommentieren deutschland sein
aber es gibt keinen lehrstuhl mit dem er
zusammenarbeiten können werden niemanden
der die grundlagen
bestätigt und dann auch beispielsweise
für die community grundlagenarbeit macht
aber auch für politik und verwaltung
und selbstverständlich gibt es da
beispiele es gibt unterschiedliche
professuren zu antisemitismus wo wir uns
ein beispiel nehmen und sagen okay
hier wurde doch schon grundlagenarbeit
gemacht ja ich gibt es leerstände zu
antisemitismus davon muss es auch noch
mehr geben es ist doch eine völlige
logische konsequenz dass man sagt okay
es muss jetzt auch ein lehrstück geben
und ich würde sagen er mehrere zu black
star ließ im parlament und anti
schwarzen rassismus in deutschland also
ich fasse mal so ihre forderung zusammen
sie wollen generell mehr gesehen war dem
namen gehört werden weil es einfach
keine faktenlage gibt dazu wie die
situation von schwarzen menschen in
deutschland ist und dementsprechend auch
keine politik ist keine politik gibt die
darauf reagieren kann das ist richtig
zusammengefasst wenn etwa das ist der
erste kleine schritt wir sind wie gesagt
hatte ich ja vor kurz erwähnt in der un
dekade für menschen afrikanischer
herkunft die hat das motto recognition
justice development anerkennung
gerechtigkeit und dann entwicklung und
ich würde es eher mit impairment
übersetzen und dass es geschieht nicht
ohne grund der erste schritt ist die
anerkennung wir müssen anerkennen dass
deutschland eine rassistisch
strukturierte gesellschaft ist das nicht
der fall müssen sich das gesund dass es
jetzt anerkannt wird
auf gar keinen fall also wo sehen sie
denn in großen debatten und vor allem in
den maßnahmen auf politischer ebene das
strukturelle rassismus irgendwie
angegangen wird
ja das werden wir jetzt sehr genau
beobachten für das antirassismus
kabinett von angela merkel das angehen
wird wie es jetzt ist im öffentlichen
diskurs wird rassismus sehr oft mit
rechtsextremismus oder mit
internationaler diskriminierung gleich
gesetzt aber eben das was sie vorher
selber genannt hatten das beispiel der
polizei sobald es auf ein
institutioneller ebene geht und auch
schon vorher gibt's diesen effekt so
nennen das hat doch nichts mit uns zu
tun
dabei müssen uns nur unsere ganzen
organisation anschauen wenn alle
führungskräfte und das nur ein indiz
alle führungskräfte weiß sind und
größtenteils männer ist das ein
anzeichen für strukturellen sexismus und
strukturellen rassismus aber es tut
natürlich weh in einer gesellschaft die
so sagen von sich selbst die erzählung
hat ein freies land zu sein und alle
hätten die gleichen möglichkeiten und
chancen das anzuerkennen dass das
vielleicht der fall sein mag aber vor
allem
für weiße männer cis männer und nicht
menschen aus anderen communitys was gab
es denn an feedback jetzt aus der
politik auf ihre forderung gab es auch
schon irgendwas oder wohl das
geflissentlich ignoriert ja wir werden
das noch ein bisschen weiter beobachten
was wir bis jetzt sehen sowohl in der
politik aber auch in den medien dass es
ein fokus darauf gibt eine
berichterstattung über
diskriminierungserfahrungen zu machen
das schwarzen menschen sozusagen in der
kamera erzählen müssen mir ist das und
das und das und das passiert und das
passiert auch oft in der politik dass
man sozusagen erst noch mal die arbeit
machen muss von den eigenen erfahrungen
zu berichten noch mal du sozusagen das
durchleben muss und wir noch nicht den
schritt gemacht haben okay jetzt letzte
mal sozusagen butter bei de fische was
machen wir denn jetzt eigentlich hatte
das jetzt schon mehrmals gesagt das
antirassismus kabinett das haben wir auf
dem schirm das hat bis jetzt noch nicht
über an die schwarzen rassismus
gesprochen ist aber auch jetzt erst noch
im anlaufen sozusagen das hätte noch gar
nicht passieren können
bis jetzt sehen wir noch keine großen
veränderungen
wir haben die erwartung dass von der
opposition wahrscheinlich ein bisschen
was kommen wird auf unterschiedlichen
ebenen das macht aber die opposition ja
auch oft so wir richten unsere
erwartungen jetzt ganz klar an die
regierungskoalition auf bundesebene und
auf landesebene um zu schauen wie sie
das thema angehen und bis jetzt habe ich
noch nichts überzeugendes gesehen
vielen dank für die zweite abend und für
die erörterung ihrer forderungen ich
bedanke mich für das zusehen und hoffe
dass es die kommentare jetzt bald von
diesen ganzen hässlichen ausführungen
gereinigt werden weil das brauchen wir
wirklich überhaupt nicht und es zeigt
leider auch dass immer noch in rassismus
problem in deutschland haben insofern
sage ich aber erstmal vielen dank für
heute und bis bald
so und wenn euch das streamen gefallen
hat dann haben wir noch ganz viele
andere für euch einmal hier entlang und
draufklicken und lassen uns auf jeden
fall mike und avoda wir freuen uns danke
tschüss